now the questions being posed to us out
of this ah really there what's on the
book
namely is it continuous right and is it
differentiable okay now because what
we're doing is we're thinking about
continuity and differentiability as
characteristics of the curve at
particular points okay it's in our
interest to know in advance well I want
to test them just randomly like let's
try zero and a half and fifty three okay
you want to look and say there are
clearly going to be some points that are
more important than others and you need
to test them okay so it's a piece no
function the easiest candidate is let's
have a look at the points where it
changes from one function to another
okay and you can clearly see minus 1 and
1 by the way we know what x squared
minus 1 looks like back to front ok how
did I know so quickly that this kind of
shape is what I was going to get for X
cubed minus X someone want to talk me
through the process right now
it's good okay so just in case you
didn't catch that right you factorized
once because everything has a factor of
X then you get differences squares now
that you get in this form it's inspector
eyes as far as you can go and once
you've got it factor price as far as you
can go you just read the roots off right
just like you would do for a quadratic
negative one zero one happy times okay
so here's what I'm going to do because
there are these two points where it
changes function minus 1 negative 1 and
1 those are the two points I'm
interested in I'm just going to
demonstrate it at one of those points
and you can repeat the process for the
other point ok first let's look at
continuity because I don't need anything
else to give that a go I'm gonna make a
little heading for myself test
continuity at x equals negative 1 okay x
equals negative 1
absolutely yeah yeah absolutely so
here's what I'm looking at
I've left it on the board intentionally
so you can see what are my conditions
for continuity I need to work out one to
three things and they're all little line
up exactly if even one of them isn't
equal to the other two then I'm busted
it's not continuous okay so I want to
think about this step by step right
first one live it as X approaches now
pause for a second I've written o here
in this order I mean it doesn't matter
what order I've got because they're all
equal to each other but I got plus here
minus here I actually kind of think it's
a little bit neater to put the don't
change it if you have written this but
I'm going to change it on the board I'm
gonna go - and then plus and then the
point I'm trying to just think logically
left to right okay so this one is from
the negative side this one's from the
positive side I'm just gonna try and do
that the same way so one approach minus
one and who want to approach it from the
left okay
so what's happening to this function at
that particular part well from the left
this is the function I'm interested in
not this one
if I'm coming from this side going along
X cubed minus X has nothing to do with
it at all okay so this is equal to the
limit as X approaches negative one and
now I don't need to worry about which
side I'm coming from because I just want
this okay are you happy with that do you
see what I'm doing because this tells me
what side to approach from now I know
which function I should be evaluating
the limit off I really should put back
into right now that okay now unlike
first principles where we first have to
really deal with minutes of this no
denominators no problems here with that
just putting in minus one so I'm going
to get this yep
do you see that I'm just evaluating okay
one minus one
zebra okay so I have a value it matches
what I expected visually but this
doesn't constitute proof okay I'm going
through the formal stuff because this
does okay
that's the first part let's have a go at
the limit as X approaches negative one
from the other side
y is made up of these two functions when
I come from the other direction
I look at a different function right I'm
coming from this side now x squared
minus one has nothing to do with that
what are you looking at the cubic X
alright so again I've no problems with
just evaluating it it's negative one
huge minus a negative one just watch
your signs okay these are critical
points where people often fudge don't do
that okay you be careful with it so you
get the right answer properly minus 1
cubed of course is this 1 plus 1 0 just
like you're expecting me to do one more
thing right which is what am I looking
for
I actually want to evaluate I want to
evaluate Y at minus 1 itself and forget
about the limits right so I say when x
equals negative 1 I suppose if you had F
notation up here f of X would equal
you could just say F of minus 1 but I
don't have that now at this point you
look right look carefully the domain and
what's defined where which function am i
interested in it's really this one right
so in practice this line that I'm about
to write is going to be identical to
this line you see that because that's
actually what I did that's how I got
that number so Y is equal I'm running
out of space I'm looking around us down
okay they're all equal one two three
they're formed I really should say or
really should say this but I'm just
running out of space down the bottom of
my page hope you can be content with
that all three things are equal
therefore it's continuous at that point
please don't just say continuous because
in a minute you're going to test the
other point over here and it may or may
not be continuous right so it's
continuous there and there only so far
well I guess I would say the limit as X
approaches negative 1 from the negative
of y equals the limit as X approaches
negative 1 positive and that all equals
F of Y of negative 1 yeah you could you
can't just write that it's just a bit
messy and not very young it's a bit it's
a bit uncommon but you will actually see
it in some textbooks because it's kind
of the way of getting around not having
F notation okay
there's continuity now I want to move
forward do you wanna ask a question yeah
yes you would so so these are the two
points I'm interested in for the sake of
illustration like I'm gonna show you how
to do continued E and then
differentiability and then you can just
repeat it again for the other one